in passato la competizione era fatto
i prezzi oggi sulla qualità in futuro
sarà sul design questa
per face professore alla harvard
business school qualche anno fa
ed effettivamente le ragione 50 anni fa
si competiva sul prezzo cioè tra due
articoli molto probabilmente avremo
acquistato l'articolo che costava di
meno
poi la competizione si è spostato sulla
qualità dove sempre tra due articoli 20
anni fa molto probabilmente avremo
acquista acquistata l'articolo
non che costava di meno ma che aveva la
qualità migliore
infine e diceva oggi la competizione in
futuro a competizione sarà fatto sul
design ed effettivamente aveva ragione
perché oggi siamo arrivati in un momento
storico dove la competizione veramente
sul design
io penso che tutti abbiamo a casa o in
tasca un telefono o un computer apple
solamente perché ha un interfaccia una
funzionalità migliore rispetto a quella
di altre compagnie
ma la domanda è che dovremmo farci come
saranno le imprese
dopo l'emergenza covip dopo il log da
non cambiamo fatto stiamo entrando in un
quarto fattore dove è diventato
importantissimo non solamente come un
prodotto e alla fine ma anche come un
prodotto viene realizzato cioè il design
e la qualità restano fondamentali
però la gente fa attenzione nel vedere
se durante la realizzazione di quel
prodotto
l'azienda ha abbracciato di valori che
loro ritengono fondamentali
c'è un bellissimo esempio che parla di
questo non so se avete presente la
pubblicità che c'è da qualche settimana
in televisione con leonardo di caprio
della nuova 500 elettrica perfetto
quella pubblicità li rappresenta
benissimo quello che sto per andare a
dirvi cioè in quella pubblicità lì non
pubblicizzano il prodotto in sé ma
pubblicizzano i valori che quel prodotto
porta infatti hanno chiamato leonardo di
caprio che è rappresentante della
sostenibilità ambientale perché perché
appunto hanno voluto pubblicizzare
questi valori io da giovane imprenditore
non voglio parlarvi sostenibilità
ambientale
ma voglio parlarvi dell'altro valore
fondamentale che è l'etica sociale
e voglio parlarne perché io ho avuto
nella mia vita un punto di riferimento
importantissimo che me l'ha trasmesso
molto banalmente anche inconsciamente e
questa persona era mio nonno mio nonno
emigrato in trentino gli anni sessanta e
aperto coi fratelli un'impresa che
lavorano marmi graniti estraggono marmi
graniti dalle cave e mio nonno ha sempre
gestito l'azienda in modo etico cioè lui
metteva le persone al centro lui
riteneva l'azienda non un fine ma un
mezzo cosa voglio dire non riteneva un
fine per guadagnare soldi ma la riteneva
un mezzo per prendere quei soldi che
guadagnava per poi distribuirli alle
persone che ne avevano più bisogno a
tutte le altre persone
io penso che lui avesse questa specie
specie di scala gerarchica nou dove
riteneva le persone più vicine a lui
come quello è un pochettino più
fortunate perché noi avevamo l'azienda e
quindi magari potevamo permetterci
qualcosina di più rispetto a quelli che
non l'avevano e quindi le persone che
erano un pochettino più lontane da lui
lui riteneva come le prime cui due a
dare il suo aiuto in caso di bisogno
e c'è un bel aneddoto che frega di
questo una volta è successo mi racconta
la mia nonna che lei doveva cambiare il
gas di casa no perché era un pomello che
non andava abbastanza bene qui andato a
mio nonno dice faustino dobbiamo
cambiare il gas di casa perché c'è un
pomello che che non va bene
io non andò li guarda sto pomello in
realtà era solamente appunto il pulsante
che non andava quindi il gas funzionava
da mangiare si poteva fare e quindi
deciso di non cambiarlo qualche giorno
dopo andò da una signora di un paese
vicino che aveva un problema molto
simile con cui fornelli del gas e niente
alla signora lo cambio è a mia nonna no
perché perché probabilmente in quel
momento riteneva più bisognava l'assegno
più bisognosa la signora rispetto a mia
nonna e lui era fatto così lui ha sempre
gestito anche l'azienda in questo modo
ha sempre lavorato in cava non ha mai
lavorato negli uffici perché era un uomo
di fatica di altri tempi e lui piaceva
lavorare con le mani però la cava veniva
e viene ancora chiusa perché si trova a
circa 1.600 metri in inverno quindi
nevicava e quindi non si poteva lavorare
e preci a milano hanno deciso di
sfruttare questi mesi in cui la cava
veniva chiusa per fare qualcosa per gli
altri per 40 anni andò in africa
coinvolgendo altri imprenditori andò in
africa fare opere di volontariato e
costruire i ponti degli acquedotti
ospedali nelle centrali elettriche
solamente per ridistribuire quello che
guadagnava durante l'anno forse la cosa
più bella che mai lasciato più segno e
qualvolta che non è andata in africa ma
è andato in perù e li ha coinvolto altri
imprenditori come lui che lavorano la
pietra e sono andati in questo posto
spettacolare no c'era questa foresta
quasi 4.000 metri di quota dove hanno
trovato questo ammasso questa montagna
gigante di granito e decisero di avviare
lì una società per l'estrazione è un
piccolo laboratorio per la lavorazione
del granito
ecco una cosa che mi rende veramente
orgoglioso è che quella società che oggi
conta 130 150 dipendenti non è intestata
la nostra famiglia ma intestata in
missionario del posto e questo è
veramente bellissimo
cioè lui riteneva l'importanza etica
delle imprese e oggi stiamo andando
veramente in questa direzione e o
dimostra un bellissimo articolo del
corriere della sera dell'anno scorso che
spiega come 181 sio americani di queste
181 aziende della round table la round
table americana è la nostra
confindustria per capirci
ecco questi 181 si hanno firmato un
trattato una tesi che dice ok le nostre
imprese non hanno lo scopo solamente di
distribuire utili agli azionisti ma ha
uno scopo più nobile il vero scopo della
nostra imprese è quello di creare valore
condiviso cosa intendono ea cui di
creare qualcosa per le altre persone
loro chiamano al valore condiviso quello
che io chiamo etica sociale e stiamo
parlando di aziende come amazon
blackrock apple
boing blackrock e latina di investimenti
più grande del mondo e quando aziende
come black rock come amazon come queste
vanno in questa direzione
vuol dire che siamo veramente di fronte
a un cambiamento enorme
in italia abbiamo un bellissimo esempio
di impresa etica idee brunello cucinelli
per chi non conoscesse brunello
cucinelli e questo l'imprenditore del
cashmere imprenditore e stilista del
cachemire brunello è nata in povertà e
quando si accorse che il papà tornava a
casa da dove lavorava umiliato dal suo
datore di lavoro si fece una promessa e
disse io non so cosa farò da grande
ma so che quello che farò lo farò per le
persone io voglio lavorare per la
dignità delle persone
perfetto oggi brunello cucinelli conta
circa 2000 dipendenti l'anno scorso ha
fatturato più di 600 milioni di euro è
uno dei miliardari italiani ma non si è
dimenticato quella promessa che si era
fatto avuto la fortuna di conoscere
cucinelli l'anno scorso ad un evento e
assieme a lui c'era un membro del suo
consiglio amministrazione andrea
pontremoli andrea pontremoli oltre a
essere consiglio amministrazione di
brunello cucinelli e membro del è
amministratore delegato di dallara
automobili e prima era amministratore
delegato di bm europa e lui in
quell'occasione racconto un aneddoto una
storiella bellissima di sé che una volta
si trovava a parigi che stava lavorando
per ibm si trova in aeroporto stava
viaggiando per lavoro ieri se avete la
chiamata brunello cucinelli e cucina e
gli disse andrea ho un'idea bellissima
ho già parlato con i proprietari fuori
dalla nostra azienda ci sono sette otto
capannoni con 50 milioni di euro li
compriamo tutti gli abbattiamo e
facciamo un bel prato
altra parte del telefono pontremoli
disse sì bonello idea bellissima è però
io come membro del tuo consiglio di
amministrazione faccio fatica
addirittura non posso approvati una cosa
del genere
effettivamente è una cosa abbastanza
difficile però quel momento chiamarono
su aereo quindi e pontremoli milito il
telefono a discussione e finì lì qualche
giorno dopo
cucinelli lo richiamò e disse andrea ci
ho pensato
effettivamente molto probabilmente il
consiglio d'amministrazione non
approverebbe mai una spesa del genere lo
faccio io quindi brunello andò mettete
50 milioni di euro delle sue azioni con
cui 50 milioni di euro a cui sto quei
capannoni li abbatte e fece un bel prato
fece un parco per la comunità
alla domanda di pontremoli ma brunello
perché hai fatto
la risposta è stata veramente bellissima
perché così è più bello e tutti possano
godere di quella bellezza c'è capite lui
ha voluto usare la sua azienda per il
bene delle altre persone è quello che
sto cercando di trasmettervi oggi
anch'io sono un giovane imprenditore è
tra i motivi tra i valori che ho voluto
portare un'azienda forse il più
importante è quello dell'etica perché
abbiamo capito che per le imprese questo
porta una cosa fondamentale a due cose
fondamentali
primo le persone che lavorano in imprese
etiche lavorano meglio stanno meglio ma
non solamente dipendenti tutti i
dipendenti gli stakeholder collaboratori
tutte le persone che hanno a che fare
con un impresa etica sono più contente
vivono meglio
cominciamo un inizio oggi da
competizione fatta su questi tipi di
valori e quindi le imprese etiche hanno
più competitività sul mercato perchè
perchè la gente attenta a questi valori
la gente preferisce acquistare in
aziende che sono attenta a questi valori
piuttosto che in aziende che questi
valori non li seguono ovviamente non
tutte le aziende possono essere come
brunello cucinelli che possono spendere
50 milioni di euro per fare un parco da
marco da donare alla comunità non
possono fare qualcosa nel loro piccolo
possono dare un qualcosa di più i
collaboratori in senso di stipendio
possono cercare di motivare o di far
seguire i loro obiettivi e collaboratori
possono cercare appunto di mettere le
persone al centro se una persona delle
esigenze possono cercare di dargli una
mano e far raggiungere i loro obiettivi
a queste persone le loro esigenze queste
persone ovviamente non solo
l'imprenditore può far questo ma anche
le persone che lavorano nelle aziende
può e deve fare questo devono in qualche
modo creare sinergie devono qualche modo
collaborare con gli altri devono in
qualche modo anche loro mettere le altre
persone che lavorano che collaborano o
con cui anche fare nelle aziende
davanti agli obiettivi di utile
aziendale e questo era messaggi come lo
trasmettervi e volevo concludere con
questa frase che mi diceva spesso mio
nonno che per me è stata il motivo di
aver aperto una impresa di essere andato
in questa direzione che è fai le cose
per gli altri
in questa frase in aggiungo una mia e
qualcosa tornerà anche a voi
grazie